[MUSIC PLAYING]
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Hello,
and welcome to I/O Live.
I'm Florina
Muntenescu, your host.
And I'm here with Matt
Henderson from Google Play.
Hello, Matt.
MATT HENDERSON: Hi.
Super excited to be here.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
So tell me what's
new in Google Play
for developers?
MATT HENDERSON: There's tons of
new stuff launching this year,
broadly speaking,
in three areas.
So we've got a whole
new format, a new app
model that's launching today.
We've also got a
bunch of new features
that help developers to do
testing and prevent bugs
in their apps.
And we also have some
features launching today,
which help developers
to manage their business
and to grow their
business on Play.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: OK.
This new app model
sounds interesting.
Can I hear more about it?
MATT HENDERSON: Yeah.
So there's really
two different things
that we're launching
within the app model.
So one is the
Android app bundle.
That's a new format,
a publishing format,
that a developer can use
that enables him to reduce
the size of their app.
The Android app bundle makes
use of a Play technology--
Play dynamic delivery.
And together, it
serves the optimal APK
for a user's given device.
And so it optimizes for the
user-specific CPU architecture
of their device.
It optimizes for their
screen densities.
It optimizes for
the user's languages
that they speak as well.
And so by only sending the parts
of the bundle that the user
actually needs, it means that
the APK that goes to the device
is a lot smaller.
And that, in turn,
enables much better
install conversion rates,
enables lower uninstall rates.
Because when the app sizes are
too big, users react badly.
And so that's something we're
launching today that I think
is going to be a big
win for developers.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
And you also mentioned
something about testing.
Tell me more.
MATT HENDERSON: As
developers, you'll
have noticed if-- during
the release process,
it's a time of risk.
Because you can have bugs
going out with a new release.
And we have new
testing track features
that help to reduce that risk.
And so you can now
use Play Publishing
for testing and
sending out the APK
to up to 100 internal
dog food testers.
So that's the internal
testing track.
We also now have multiple
testing tracks for close betas.
And then, also to help you
reduce the bugs in your apps
and improve that
quality, there's
some new features
in Android Vitals
and new features in
the pre-launch report.
In Vitals, we have new
metrics, like app startup time.
We've also launched a new
overview page in Vitals
that draws your
attention to anomalies.
If some of the Vitals
metrics are particularly bad,
then it'll highlight
those to you
so you know which
ones to prioritize.
With the pre-launch
report-- so that
is the automated crawler
that tests apps prior to them
going into production.
And we've launched
some new features today
that enable you to reach further
into the corners of your app
that the crawler might not
have otherwise reached.
Features like, a developer
can record scripts
in Android Studio that
help the crawler to go
into particular
parts of the app.
Game developers,
if you use Open GL,
you can create demo loops that
help the pre-launch report
crawler to reach different
parts of your app as well.
And so all these
features will mean
that once your app
hits production,
it's been much more scrutinized,
eliminating more of these bugs.
We're launching a
new app dashboard
in the console, which
summarizes a range
of different statistics.
It's, I think, much easier at
drawing the user into the most
important metrics.
You can also
configure the page now
depending on which ones
are priorities for you.
And we have some
new business stats
that we're launching as well.
For subscription developers, if
you have a subscription model,
there is now a more complex
view to understand it at greater
detail of different subscription
states-- subscriber states--
and how you benchmark retention
for your app versus other apps
as well.
You can look at new metrics,
like average revenue per user.
There's new data about the
acquisition and user retention
funnel.
There you can also
compare your stats
for your app against
benchmark for peer apps
that are functionally similar.
So all of these
things hopefully help
developers discover
opportunities
that can enable them to grow
and be successful in Play.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Perfect.
Lots of new things for
developers, but also
for the business side.
Thank you, Matt.
This is Florina for I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]